c'est le premier album de neil young
veins année j'attends ce moment non mais
tu vas rire quand j'ai commencé ma
collection je me suis dit le jour du
bois écouter tranquillement ni loueur tu
seras un homme heureux
je peux parler juste à 28 mètres ça
t'embête pas là maintenant à cause de
sébastien fait rien de ses journées
bonjour mon grand papa de coeur par
exemple je fais de la tête car dit qu'on
finira par le foot me myself en l'air
à mesure des semis ciel puis c'est
l'amour il faut des rafales à la pêche
et vous sur votre mari vous attend il
est membre
heil et ma mère kabyle c'est vrai
que tu fais là je passe l'aspirateur non
lieu à la fin c'est le mieux pour nous
de l5 pour bien je te dis qu'elle n'a
rien découvert
que non encore le plafonnement salon et
est complètement imbibé d'eau je ne vous
propose pas d'entrée allongé sur non je
ne le propose pas ce que je suis
affreusement retard la leo c'est
possible ne pas faire de bruit mais avec
ces charmants je veux dire qu'est ce que
tu fais ici dire la vérité la thalie
mais pourquoi aujourd'hui pourquoi
justement vous en demandez jamais
comme c'est un vrai sens de la fin je
t'ai dit que je voulais écouter cet
album mais qu'est ce que ces personnes
la fête des voisins sinon c'est vraiment
ma journée et égoïste égoïste moi moi
tout ça est ce que tu fais là et je
voulais te parler mais voulait
m'entendre tu avais tu veux faire
craquer ça est un gros gros problème
mais nous a demandé de faire un bureau
pas une décision ferme sur la
consternation
mais moi pas sous l'eau commence à toi
pas assurance mais vous payez moins noir
ah oui c'est vrai c'est sale ça c'est
vrai ça aussi